Joe Biden is ready to
Tango Donald Trump say ready to debate
you right now do you
accept on radio toate to immediately he
say
immediately if I him I want to debate me
too you got nothing else to do oh my but
somebody's getting ahead of their
depends Donald Trump scoring his largest
lead yet against Joe Biden in the latest
poll by NBC and increasing his lead
there by Five Points Donald is up 23
points when it comes to who has the
better mental and physical health to be
president Trump also blows Biden out of
the water on the economy besting Joe by
more than 20 points and black voters are
a big reason
why I mean you know Donald Trump has a
reputation of uh being the money man
reading some of the things that he talks
about with business I can kind of agree
with as far as business wise cuz I'm I'm
I'm trying to to grow my business um as
far as Biden I haven't seen Biden really
care about business like that a lot of
my friends are obviously my age so we're
a little younger we've only voted once
you know for act for a president and
Trump is kind of all we know we were
broke with Biden we weren't with Trump
and that's kind of the only thing that
I'm hearing over and over with numbers
that bad the media is going to need a
whole Squad of therapy llamas to
cope economic poll numbers for President
Biden come despite most of the key
economic indicators remaining extremely
strong the economy is so striking Steve
because jobs are up inflation is down
voters aren't giving him credit for that
clearly how do you solve it when people
have concluded that you are not fit to
be the president of the United States
today let alone four more years I'll
just say it right here a lot of them
shocking to me I mean outrageous
everything cutting again which again for
me is is is so Preposterous it's
laughable yeah no facts in there Jesse
uh Joe Biden says he's not going to do
the interview in the Super Bowl Halftime
is this an opportunity for Trump to do
it shouldn't CBS say hey because he's
really the president right now yes did
you you didn't mean that see what you
did there well listen this is what nor
O'Donnell doing it last year it was
Brett who we canceled on this is Nora
they only wanted 3 minutes MH oh this is
an election year you're dodging the
Super Bowl interview you're not really
campaigning for president if you're
dodging that's softball after softball
the First question's on Ukraine second's
Gaza the third question is what are you
going to eat when you watch the game
that's three minutes he can't survive
that that tells you everything you need
to know now the media's lost touch with
the street now I have my ear on the
street when I say my ear I mean Johnny
Johnny Goes out there and talks to
people barber shops wherever he's at and
it's the same thing there was money in
your pocket four years ago now there's
not as much if you look at that wage
growth chart Greg I know you sleep with
that chart you know it wage growth after
the Trump economic tax and regulation
policies kicked in went wo through the
roof wages skyrocketed and then fouches
funded Wuhan lab just killed it and then
Biden's energy and spending policies
tripled the wage recovery so people
don't have as much money now and that's
just the bottom line you can talk about
these Wall Street numbers like GDP and
jobs but that doesn't it misses the
kitchen table issue that people are
really
feeling unlike you unlike me yes Harold
I go to you for no particular reason
blacks like everybody else the economy
matters maybe the lesson for Democrats
is the only color that brings the
country together is
green what say you Harold for J being in
that barber shop watching the the barber
shop scene there um it's something that
frankly I'm hearing uh in from friends
and others around the country who have
their their own Johnnies that out
helping them understand what's happening
I'd say a couple things to Democrats one
and to the White House you making a
mistake not to do the Super Bowl
interview I think Jesse is right in
terms of the two or three questions
amount of time it gives a qu president
opportunity to get as many reps in his
practic as he may need and others may
need to begin to lay out the agenda and
the vision for the campaign two when the
president walks out of an event he's got
to regardless of the question be railing
off point after point after Point why he
should be reelected uh there shouldn't
be any waiting for the question uh
trying to be funny about things this is
a serious moment this this polling data
this is the first time in my lifetime
where both what should say when Mrs
Clinton Secretary Clinton and then
candidate Donald Trump both of them had
plus 95% name recognition and people
felt like they knew them this will be
the same we've never had two former one
president and a former president in my
lifetime running against one another so
everybody knows them so you have to be
on your aame every time you get off that
helicopter when you get off that plane
when you come out the Oval Office and
certainly when you come out an ice cream
shop uh if you're on a campaign Trail
finally this issue with black men is
serious uh I started with it Jesse and
and and and Greg started with it uh you
should take seriously what those young
men are saying because I don't think it
was just isolated to those four young
men there it's not animosity towards the
president what it's saying is you're not
speaking to You're not meeting me where
we are there are things in our lives
that are not broken but are in disrepair
help us to fix them and the candidate
that is able to do that uh will have the
best chance there are three dates I say
all the time in the presidential your
Memorial Day what gas prices are the 4th
of July what food prices are and early
August when schools across the country
we start late here in New York at the
South where I'm from in the midwest
where kids are starting in early August
the back to school prices for kids this
is a big big those three moments and
then obviously after lab after Labor Day
the things gets really going here uh you
got to get focused on this faster and I
hope you reverse your decision on Super
Bowl I want to see you before the Super
Bowl Mr President I want to tell want
you to tell me again why you should be
president again judge uh the Dems as you
saw in that Montage kept talking about
this robust economy but the Americans
American people people don't feel it and
they're actually like going what's wrong
with you people why don't you notice
this yeah you know chrisen Welker in
particular she's truly shocked by this
stunning Biden Trump poll you know why
they live in their own world of trump
derangement they live in a world where
they hate Trump so much they're not
listening to regular Americans whether
it's in a barber shop and I was so
impressed with that or or whether it's
in a supermarket but something is
happening in America today something is
happening when you've got immigration as
the number one issue and you've got
Trump beating Biden by 30 points when
Biden has the opportunity to formulate
policy on that very issue you've got
Americans now who are angry they
remember what president Trump tried to
do they remember the the the the the the
beat down by the Democrats on the wall
and every other issue of racism and it
was xenophobic and all this other stuff
and they're like wait a minute and when
it comes to the blacks in particular
because I'm answering you when it comes
to blacks in particular and I didn't
turn around and look at you for that one
when it comes to blacks in particular I
said when he went from 85 to 62% a drop
of 25% in black voter support for Biden
I thought a lot of that had to do with
the fact that you know here's Donald
Trump this guy is getting prosecuted
like we are but the bigger thing now is
immigration and how that intersects
because immigration is now affecting
black uh Americans and minorities in
this country where they are watching in
real time there school programs schools
sports centers gyms all these places
where black parents and black mothers in
particular have an opportunity to send
their kids after school to school
programs to keep them out of the gangs
to keep them away from selling drugs to
keep them occupied are being taken away
from them they are Americans and they're
being given to illegals about whom we
know nothing who can beat down of police
officers and then get bailed uh
immediately and let out and run to
another state that doesn't happen to
African-Americans in this country but
it's happening to illegals and you know
what that's going to Blossom at the top
of the at the top the highest race in
this country it is interesting Dana uh
the way the judge lays it out it almost
sounds like uh migrants are getting
reparations
wait a second how did you get in front
of us they're called pre preparations
pre preparations before you are a
citizen even you get all of these
benefits um a couple of things from me
um Biden ran a basement campaign in 2020
they would love to reprise that that's
part of the not doing the Super Bowl
interview because to me for them the
risk is too great yeah because the
number one issue and one of the issues
in the poll from NBC News was competency
and age and as my friend Colin Reed says
father time is undefeated and that is
one of his biggest problems so I
actually personally am okay with the
Super Bowl tradition going away for
president like enough like maybe we can
all just take a pass on that and it
would be fine but it is interesting that
they'll pass it up but I think it's
because the risk is too great also
wanted to point out that do you remember
last May ABC News had a poll that had
Biden and Trump about at this uh polling
level and ABC News tried to disavow
their own poll and said this is an
outlier this isn't happening this is is
actually real and the the stories about
black men they're proliferating uh The
Washington Post had one about all the
economic issues plus the other thing
that this didn't capture aside from
black men it's the high credit card debt
impossible to buy a home hard to get
child care cars are still expensive but
car insurance is also extremely
expensive house insurance is very
expensive so everything is up and that's
why if the stock market is up that's
great for a lot of people jobs Also may
be good but it's going to take a while
for people to feel a lot better about
the economy maybe Trump should do
halftime at the Puppy Bowl the Puppy
Bowl like how does that go well they
have a halftime and he does a Q&A with
the with the dog whisperer oh puppy
puppy ball you don't know the puppy ball
no we watch the real game The Puppy Bowl
is better than the Super Bowl come on
people you know I'm right all right up
next kamla rolling up her pants suit for
a 2028 presidential campaign hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else